Hello everybody!
Okay guys, I woke up a little bit.
Because like, I woke up and then I was like, wait a minute.
Where's my room?
Where's my, where's my good night dragon's room?
My room!
Because like, so you know how I'm on a new PC.
So because of that, I forgot to, some of the assets I forgot to move.
What is it being?
The room I broke into.
You know, the room I'm borrowing for good night dragoons.
So that was like, six minutes of me trying to find, find, you know, because you know, I'm directionally challenged.
So I didn't bring my map with me to find this room again.
The map was in my old PC.
And so like, I had to get Google Maps and try to figure out like, where is this room that broke into for good night dragoons?
I also sort of got a head, a head start in the good night part.
Because I took a nap.
I took a nap.
I'm so tired.
I got...
I got a little head start with the good night part, and started eating before I did the good night stream.
So...
So yeah.
I'm Sorry.
I'm so tired.
I'm sorry Are you eating?
Yes!
Uhm...
I woke up, Oh, and I was like, I like dragged myself out of... okay, and then like I woke up fucking stun locked by my alarm because I get the... my alarm...
I know I shouldn't have this as my alarm because it's like, you know, it's It gives people like PTSD, but it works.
Yes.
I know it gives people PTSD Because it's like the worst alarm in the world, but it works So my alarm is literally the classic Apple alarm, you know the one that was like Like that one.
I mean I could play it right now and give you guys PTSD if you really want it hear it
Like the ones that are like right now trying to like use this stream as
It's supposed to be!
Goodnight dragon!
No, don't do it!
Okay.
All right by my side I'm not joking I won't put you... I won't put you through that But yes, I use the I use the PTSD alarm to To wake myself up cuz it fucking works like of course I would use it.
Like yes, I know it's terrible but like terrible Even though it's terrible It works you can't deny that it wakes you up D dragon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Silly dokey.
This is goodnight dragoons.
Not good morning dragoons Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Anaya, thank you for the super chat.
I couldn't catch up for one of the... couldn't catch one of the three first three from bad luck So this is a fun hello and reunion once!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh wow Okay, various does not give a fuck about you So does Mike Nova No, it was just like please five more minutes.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Nova won it silence, but but various and Mike are chaotic evil Alright, let me see last off my lo-fi, you know what's coming up now Apple alive, okay, where is it?
Oh Okay.
Give me a sec, I don't even know of it's this one No, this is the soft one Apple alarm What was it called Alarm No that is the that's the nice one
What's the name of it guys?
That's the standard one do you Alarm.
Is it this one?
No, that's just an alarm clock.
That's just the alarm.
Don't tell me!
Oh, is it the nuclear?
Yeah, okay.
Is it this one?
Okay.
Which one is the one that I have?
Is this?
Oh, this is it.
This is my alarm.
Wake up!
There you go.
Free alarm voice pack for you guys.
Wake up, dragons!
Wake up!
That's my alarm.
So, you guys have... guys, you literally got a free alarm voice pack, guys.
Congratulations!
For free.
Well, not for free.
Some of the dragons kicked...
kicked... was it crowdfunding?
Leon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Stop, please!
Anyway, this was... this is my alarm.
Too late.
It already stopped.
The alarm is too quiet.
You should play again.
But way louder.
Remember, this is... this is an employee of my team.
He's... he's literally gets paid to tell me to put it louder.
Be careful, sound guy.
That's how revolts start.
You're so evil.
Sound guy, no!
You're supposed to be for the people!
What happened?
Sound guy!
Hmm.
Anyway.
Um.
Wake me up.
I need to work.
Anyway.
Um.
What was that?
Yes!
I was gonna say I am eating something right now.
I am eating...
元子甘农.
So for those who don't know what it is...
I'm trying to remember what the English name is again.
It's a mango pomelo sago.
So basically it is a...
It is a famous Hong Kong dessert.
Um.
It's actually one of my favorite desserts in the world.
So...
Uh...
Uh.
And I woke up.
I dragged myself to my PC.
And then my dad just got home.
And he was like...
Oh hey!
Do you want 元子甘农?
We just bought it.
And I was like...
Yes!
Yes I won!
Um.
Uh.
I think it was...
Wait wait.
I want to make sure I say your name correctly.
Grabbing up my Google Translate.
Because I can't read any language.
Let alone English.
English.
I can't read English.
Sato!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I really appreciate it!
Doc!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Wait.
You pay your mods?
Yes!
I pay my mods now!
If you guys didn't know.
Um.
I recently started paying my mods starting...
I think like...
Was it last month?
Um.
I don't remember.
Some of my mods can...
Any of my mods can like...
Uh.
Fact check me.
But like...
I started paying my mods...
I think like last month or the month before.
Uh.
Because I make enough to pay them now!
Where like...
I make...
Um.
And it's because of you guys!
That I can provide like...
You know.
I can actually provide like...
Uh.
Provide money for my mods.
To let them keep doing what they're doing.
So yes.
They do get paid now.
And...
Uh.
They used to do this work for free.
Out of the goodness of their hearts.
And because they are...
Uh.
They love working for me.
And now...
Now I pay them.
Because I think they still love working.
And now I pay them because it's Stockholm Syndrome now.
Now I can never leave.
Uh.
Potter!
Thank you for the 20 gift-a-ships!
Thank you!
I really appreciate it!
Thank you so much!
Uh.
Yeah.
They get...
They get yelled at by me.
And they get paid.
Now you can leave!
Yeah.
They're too deep to leave now!
So yes!
They do get paid!
Yay!
I know like it's not really like a common thing to do.
Like paying your mods.
Um.
Because like I said like you know.
Uh.
You have to be able to...
I guess like...
To be able to earn enough.
To be able to do so.
Because there's always like there's so many other expenses going on behind the scenes.
Um.
But luckily...
Finally I am able to like...
Uh.
I guess like...
Be able to do all these projects.
Be able to...
Uh.
Do all these projects.
Plan all these things.
Uh.
All my expenses.
And also...
Pay my mods!
Because you see them here almost every stream.
And I really appreciate it.
I really appreciate them being there.
Every stream.
Um.
And doing so many things for me.
You know.
Advertise...
Reminding me to...
Advertise stuff.
Because I always forget.
Um.
Uh.
My mods always reminding me about like obligations that I have to do.
Like you know.
Be like...
Hey guys!
Remember that I'm sponsored by YouTube and GamerStuff?
I always forget to say stuff like that.
Don't worry.
My mods got me.
Uh.
They post...
They give us like reminders and everything in chat.
Which is great.
Uh.
So yes!
And then we have Sound Guy who does like sound check up.
Like I always say...
I say...
I think that like...
One of the most important things...
You need to have...
When it comes to like...
If you want to be a streamer...
Is to have good sound quality.
Like...
Like the first thing...
People would look at...
Is if like...
The sound quality is okay.
Like the audio balancing and stuff is okay.
Because at the moment...
If the audio balancing is not great...
They leave.
They leave the stream.
Because...
I hate watching streams with bad audio balancing.
So I assume you guys would hate it too.
That's why I have a dedicated Sound Guy.
And I always...
Like give them...
Like...
Like my feedback too.
Give my Sound Guy...
My feedback.
Being like...
Hey...
I think I prefer...
Like if...
Like if we continue doing this game...
If I do a part two...
I prefer the game sound was...
A little bit louder.
Or like...
I didn't like how the game sound was...
Louder than me.
So could you like balance that...
In regards to that next time?
Because like...
Then you get to know my preferences and everything.
So yeah...
The Sound Guy gets yelled at me...
Almost like every other show.
So yeah...
The Sound Guy sort of...
Gets scolded by me every...
Like every two to three streams.
So they deserve to get paid.
Yeah...
But they get paid.
So it's fine.
So it's okay.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
No...
Don't keep...
No don't keep...
Shut up!
But yeah...
Also...
I sort of...
Low...
Okay...
It wasn't low key...
Because...
Because that tweet got a lot of traction.
But...
I sort of like...
Revealed...
That...
The whole year...
Technically...
Is...
A little bit...
Booked...
With...
Events...
Or projects...
Or sponsors...
So...
Every month...
There's something to look forward to guys.
I...
I know I said fully booked...
But...
Hey guys...
If you wanna...
Sponsors...
I know I said it's fully booked...
But...
I might let you guys...
Sneak into the calendar...
Because I can't say no...
But I can slide you right in...
Sponsors...
Don't worry...
Fully booked...
With...
Exceptions...
Like I said...
The reason why...
I know like...
I saw like...
People were like...
Doki...
Please...
Rest...
There's so many announcements...
When do they stop?
You gotta rest!
Stop?
What do you mean?
It's the Doki year...
It's the year of the Doki...
What do you mean?
Stop?
If you think those are all the conventions I'm gonna go...
This year...
Guys...
It says...
World Tour...
There's...
A specific...
There's a...
Some...
There's a region that I haven't listed yet...
In terms of conventions...
Guys...
We have conventions for NA...
We have conventions for EU...
But we are missing conventions for a region...
That we haven't announced yet...
That's not...
That's...
That's like...
You know...
There's no conventions announced yet...
For a region...
Um...
And I did say...
World Tour...
Okay...
I'm sorry...
But...
I don't want to get your hopes up...
But I don't want to lie...
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry...
I have to like...
I saw...
I saw a lot of people very excited...
I'm sorry...
Guys...
I have to let you guys down right now...
Doki!
No!
You said...
World Tour...
Doki!
What do you mean?
I'm sorry...
Guys, all I'm saying is like, guys you gotta get conventions to invite me there guys.
I think a lot of conventions in Latin America don't know who I am.
I haven't got any invite from Latin America, I'm so sorry.
If I had, if I get an invite, I would say yes.
Guys, I would say yes if I get an invite over there, but I don't think I got a single invite yet.
I'll say yet, because maybe, maybe next year or the end of the year, it'll be different.
Like, I was gonna... guys, I had to like, let, I had to let like, South America down.
I don't, I don't wanna get their hopes up, I'm so sorry.
But other than that, there's a region...
...
Excluding South America, I'm very sorry.
I'm very sorry!
That we haven't, that we haven't announced a convention for it yet.
So keep your eyes open, cause there's more announcements coming!
Uh-huh.
Squibbly, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Cries in Spanish.
Zpie, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
How do you feel about onion rings or ring pops?
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I mean, onion rings are pretty, um, uh, pretty goaded.
I like onion rings.
I haven't had a ring pop in so long.
I think it's cause it's like, it's like super sweet.
I haven't had a ring pop in a long time.
I don't like candy.
I'll just say, I'm not a big fan of candy.
I prefer chocolate more than candy.
The only types of candy I like is cotton candy.
But only like cotton candy ice cream.
Um, I like, I can't have like, like I don't know.
It's just, it's just, I'm not a huge fan of like, um, candies in general.
I just think it's like way too sweet.
So I prefer, I prefer just chocolate.
I like milk chocolate.
But then people will call me a loser for liking milk chocolate.
But I am not afraid to tell you what I like.
I'm not, I'm here to represent the milk chocolate gang.
You'll say people who like milk chocolate are losers.
But I don't care.
I might be the biggest loser out there.
But I will defend milk chocolate.
They give the magenta soup.
But they can thank you.
But we have money.
They give the magenta soup.
But they can, they might say milk chocolate is for babies.
But I know what I like.
I hate dark chocolate.
Okay, um, fuck dark chocolate.
That is my controversial statement of the day.
That is my, that is my, um, my hate statement of the day.
Fuck dark chocolate.
It wishes it was as good as milk chocolate.
I know dark chocolate is healthy for you.
Because the darker the chocolate, the more cocoa in the chocolate.
The more healthy.
The more health benefits you get.
You can try and cancel me.
But I know what I like.
It's okay to be wrong.
Dark chocolate.
It does, I just don't, it's just bitter.
It tastes bitter.
I just don't like dark chocolate.
It tastes so bitter.
It doesn't matter if it's healthier.
I'm not eating chocolate to be healthy.
Like what the fuck is chocolate?
Chocolate is like the cheap food.
Why am I eating chocolate to be healthier?
I eat what I want to eat to be like, I want to eat something sweet today.
You're tasting the wrong one.
Look, it's okay to be wrong.
I'm thinking of a super chat.
Thank you.
It's okay.
You're still my Oshii.
Even that's higher.
Thank you.
It's okay to be wrong.
I mean, I'm right obviously.
Yes.
Okay.
I know.
Milk chocolate is cheaper.
But I am the, I am for the people.
I'm not the bourgeoisie.
That's why I am for the people.
That's why I like milk chocolate more than dark chocolate.
I am for the people.
Dark chocolate just tastes better.
I mean, yeah.
If you don't have enough, yeah.
If you don't have enough taste buds, I guess you can see.
I'm going to start a chocolate.
Chocolate war.
Borg, thank you for the five...
gift of chips.
Thank you.
I like how this is where I cross the line.
By talking dark chocolate.
By being a milk choc- Like by having milk chocolate as my Oshie.
This is the line where it's crossed.
This is where dragoons feel attacked.
That was the moment.
The downfall of DokiBaron.
When she gave her opinion on chocolate.
But yes, that is what I prefer.
And then like if you like regular.
I guess like...
And then there's some freaks that like the medium between the two.
Like regular chocolate.
Like why?
Why?
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
I think it's funny.
Have you guys... you know like what was it?
The Mr. Beast Feastables?
Apparently... okay.
Oh my gosh.
Mr. Beast is so fucking rich.
Like...
The fact that he just threw money at it.
And managed to convince a giant population of children to think that feastable chocolates like taste good.
Like taste good.
I'm gonna put this in my video.
I'll play Minecraft for you.
Mr. Beast.
If you send me a package of feastables.
Don't worry my calendar is open for you Mr. Beast.
So if you want to send me...
I see you sending content creators...
Feastable...
Feastable chocolates.
And like you know...
I can easily change my opinion.
You know?
I won't call it a bribe.
But like...
I mean everybody loves free stuff.
Um...
Gio thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
People who like dark chocolate are old people.
Milk chocolate is the best.
I didn't say that.
That was Gio.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I didn't say that.
That was Gio's opinion.
I mean her opinion is right.
But like I didn't say that.
Like it's not my opinion.
No.
Um...
Black thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Um...
Unfollows my mutual.
No you know like...
Old people...
You know like old people always have like...
The old people candy.
Like the...
The straw...
You know like the strawberry wrapped candy.
And then like the caramel...
Where do they get those?
How do all the elderly just know exactly what to buy?
The grandma candies.
Yeah.
Like where...
Yeah the hard caramel.
And then like the strawberry wrapped...
Uh...
The strawberry wrapped...
Not strawberry.
You know like those candies that have a strawberry wrapping.
Those ones.
Where do they get those?
The dollar store?
There's no way.
There's no way grandmas are giving us dollar store candy.
Ha ha ha.
I feel like every elderly person just knows exactly...
Um...
Like where to get those candies.
Oh my gosh there's something else I want to talk about.
When it came to candy.
Sorry.
My brain is like still waking up.
It's like I need to rev my brain up.
I need to...
Oh!
But you know okay.
There's one I really...
Really miss.
People...
People in Asia might know what I'm talking...
You know like seitan?
You know that?
That shit was so good.
That and the rabbit one.
I don't remember what the rabbit candy is called.
So like...
There's like two candies I really...
They're actually like my favorite candies.
Like I know...
I'm not like a huge fan of candies.
But like if I see like seitan...
And um... the rabbit one.
The rabbit one.
Like I love that shit so much.
Yes the white rabbit.
Yeah!
That shit is so good.
Okay.
Alright for those who don't know about it or like don't live in Asia.
Or never seen it in like...
Um... Asian market.
You guys should really try these candies.
They're so fucking good.
That's like literally my childhood.
I don't eat it anymore because like...
I don't eat candy.
Ha ha ha.
I don't eat candy anymore.
But like if it does show up I will like...
You know... I will take one.
I'll take a piece.
Then...
Licy...
Uh... candy.
And there's licy candy.
Oh my gosh how do you...
Wait is it...
Uh... pocket candy?
What's it called in English?
Oh it is!
It's called Chinese good luck candy.
Okay this shit is fire.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
That shit is actually so good.
Alright yes it's JPEG.
Okay I'll post it.
I can show it on screen too.
Alright guys.
You guys gotta try this.
It's actually fire.
This shit is like so fucking good.
Um...
It's honestly like one of my favorite candies in the world.
I don't eat it as much anymore.
Like I barely eat candy these days.
But uh...
This shit is really good.
It's called... in English apparently it's called...
Uh... Chinese good luck candy.
I like how it's called Chinese good luck candy.
Good luck candy.
I like how it says good luck candy.
Guys if you eat it you get more good luck.
Anyway there's another one.
And this one is like white rabbit candy.
Um... it's called creamy candy.
Uh... please...
Uh... don't pay attention to the...
I know it's very...
Uh... weirdly named.
I know it's...
It's a little... the name is a little bit like...
Inappropriate.
But like trust me it's...
Don't focus on the creamy candy part.
Focus on the white rabbit.
Hahahaha.
Focus on white rabbit.
I didn't realize this was also the name.
Um...
Carlos thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That smug smile on my skin is really cute.
Also milk chocolate.
I told you.
For the people.
White chocolate is the best.
Okay but like...
Okay I'll tell you guys a story.
Um... there's a reason also why I don't eat this anymore.
Because it's also associated with like...
A low key traumatic experience.
Because I like... but like...
I like this candy too much.
So what happened...
Was that um...
Cough cough cough.
Younger Doki was quite impulsive.
Hahahaha.
Little...
Little child Doki was a very Impulsive individual.
And like somebody left This bag candy Out in the open.
While I was uh...
Visiting... I think I was visiting my aunt or some shit.
So like um...
Um...
So little...
Little Doki was a very impulsive...
Not anymore of course.
Hahahaha.
I'm different now of course.
Guys.
But little Doki was very impulsive.
So you know...
Okay so like the thing about this particular...
Uh...
The thing about this particular...
Type of candy...
Is that...
It's very chewy and sticky.
So...
You know what little Doki did?
Little Doki...
I don't know how many I had.
Hahahaha.
But...
I stuffed my mouth...
With like at least...
Four to five...
Plus...
At once...
Instead of you know...
Sucking it like...
How you normally do with...
Hard candy...
I started chewing.
Hahahaha.
And...
And when you chew...
It gets stickier.
So...
What happened to little Doki...
Is that...
Um...
So I had silver teeth.
I don't know if I still...
I think I still do.
But like I had silver teeth.
Instead of braces.
Um...
Because I don't know if this is like an Asian thing.
But like...
But like I knew like back then instead of getting braces...
We...
People would get like silver...
Silver like...
They would put like silver casings...
Over...
Over like the tooth.
So...
What happened?
Yeah the silver jackets.
It's like not even like silver...
It's like they are like jackets over a tooth instead of braces.
Uh...
Were for cavities.
Oh...
I didn't realize it was for cavity.
I thought they were for...
I was told they were for braces.
Well anyway...
I was a bad child.
That explains a lot.
Actually.
Okay.
Anyway.
That explains a lot.
That they were actually for cavities.
Anyway.
Um...
So yes.
I started chewing.
And yeah.
It was like a candy.
And the jacket...
Got stuck on the candy.
And it got off.
It got...
The casings...
Got off the tooth.
Because of the candy.
So...
Little Toki.
Despite loving White Rabbit.
She doesn't eat a lot of that candy anymore.
I still remember...
That moment.
Because I was very little Toki.
But because...
It was a long time ago.
But I still remember that moment.
It's like...
There's like flashbulb memories.
So if you guys don't know.
Flashbulb memory is basically...
A moment that's so traumatic.
That you'll always...
You'll be like 90 years old.
And you'll still remember that day.
This is my flashbulb memory.
It is...
My core memory.
So yes.
Little Toki doesn't eat a lot of candy anymore.
Adult Toki...
Also doesn't eat a lot of candy anymore.
Like I mean...
If I do see a White Rabbit candy.
I'll have one.
Yes of course they do.
It's famous.
I'll have like one.
Not 5+.
Like I used to.
I'll have like one.
The candy trauma.
This is also why I'm more so of a...
Of a chocolate gal now.
I only really have chocolate.
Instead of...
Instead of candy.
One is enough for me.
Yeah.
It just reminds me.
When I used to live in Asia.
People don't celebrate Halloween.
And like...
I had to...
The only place you can go like trick or treating.
Is like...
Okay.
So like...
I used to go to international schools.
Yeah.
So like I told you guys about this.
I used to go...
Also because the other reason why there's no like...
There's no like trick or treating.
Is because...
A lot of...
Houses are expensive.
Like people don't normally live in houses in the city in Asia.
Because like...
I think it's also because there's no actual...
Like there's no suburbia.
Like you don't...
There's no actual suburbia in...
In Asia.
It's just apartments.
It's just mostly just apartment buildings.
And yeah there's not a lot of space in everything.
So it's just like usually there's no room for it.
It's just apartments.
If you live in a house in Asia.
You're fucking rich as hell.
Or you live on the...
Countryside.
Because like property is much cheaper there.
Because there's also like usually there's no internet.
Uh...
There's no really internet there.
So like property is a lot cheaper.
So yeah.
So like if you live in a house.
You're fucking loaded.
You're like an actual millionaire.
So...
Yeah.
More like you're living in like...
You live in an area where there's...
It's not really a city.
Um...
Uh... Anyway.
Anyway so there's no Halloween.
There's no trick or treating.
Because there's like...
You can't really trick or treat.
In like apart...
You can't really trick or treat in buildings.
It's just apartments.
So it's really funny.
So I used to go to international school.
Yeah.
So I used to go to international schools.
Um...
They basically...
Uh... So that...
I guess like the Americans don't get culture shock.
Um...
It's so...
When I think about it...
Um...
When you...
Okay.
It's really funny.
But like I went to international school.
And one of them...
They want to make sure like I guess like the Americans...
Don't get culture shock.
Like you know...
No Halloween and stuff like that.
Or like...
They built their own suburbia.
For the school.
So like the school...
Was located in its own...
Gated community.
Where it was like...
Literally like all the majority of the American families...
Would live there.
Because it would be like their own suburbia.
Obviously I wasn't living there.
I was a flirty 30 plus...
Minute drive.
I didn't.
Um...
Later on they expanded.
Like the school got bigger and bigger.
Because they couldn't fit in the gated community.
So they bought like other buildings.
The school like used to own a...
Like it used to own...
Uh...
There was a building that was supposed to be a mall.
And then the school bought it.
And then it became like the middle school slash high school.
And they had escalators and shit like that.
It was fucking crazy.
And then the school...
That building they bought for middle slash high school...
Was not even supposed to be a school.
So they had like elevators and everything.
Uh...
Escalators.
So they had like escalators.
And they had like escalators and shit.
Not elevators.
Escalators and stuff.
Um... But anyway.
I thought it was really funny.
Like I thought... I didn't think it was weird back then.
Because like...
This was like one of the first international schools I went to.
I didn't think it was weird.
Because like you know...
Little Doki was like...
Oh yeah it's just like suburbia.
You know?
I was like...
Whoa it's like suburbia.
Where there's like houses and stuff.
And like...
Villas and stuff.
Where like all the Americans.
So they don't feel weird.
They don't feel...
They don't feel like culture shock.
From living in America.
From living in Asia.
So basically what's so funny is that like...
All the students.
All like the... you know all the students.
And the kids.
They would go...
Yes it was a gated community.
Because like when you have to enter the school.
To enter the community.
You need a special pass.
To even like drop your kids off.
Because they're like...
We don't want kid... you know they don't want kidnappers.
To come in.
To like just pick...
Because it's like there's preschool as well.
There's preschool too.
So like they don't want like you know some...
Because there's like...
There's some really rich people there.
Because a lot of people... if you don't know international schools.
A lot of people that go to like...
They are like...
Because like a lot of people that...
A lot of the adults that...
You know have to go to like...
Asia and stuff.
And put their kids to international school.
They're usually are working for like...
Really big companies.
And their companies sent them to like...
Certain Asian countries.
To like expand the company and stuff like that.
So like you would see like you know...
Executives, children and stuff.
Like I had an actual...
Oh what is it called?
Like...
I had...
An actual...
Saudi princess.
That went to one of my international schools.
Like legitimately.
She was a Saudi princess.
I'm not joking.
I am not joking.
Like she was like...
I remember because she was like...
She was like my senior.
She was like two years...
Older than me.
And like...
We had an event.
Where it was like...
Secret Santa.
We had an event that was like Secret Santa.
And...
And everyone was like...
Oh my god.
Her hair is my Secret Santa.
I was like hoping she would be...
Like their Secret Santa.
Because like I was like...
Why does everyone want her to...
Want her to be like the Secret Santa.
And people were like...
Bro she's like fucking loaded.
She bought...
Okay they won't say fucking.
But they were like bro she's loaded.
Like she actually buys the most insane gifts for you.
If you get her as a Secret Santa.
I was like...
Bro like what?
Yeah one of them was like...
Yeah bro she got me like...
A Beats by Dre headphone.
And like a design...
I don't know what it was but like...
She gets like multiple presents.
For a little oil...
Yeah she like gives you like...
Beats by Dre headphones.
And that was when Beats by Dre was like super popular by the way.
And was like...
And it was like...
And like it's not just that she gets you more than...
She got me a designer bag.
And Beats by Dre.
Like someone was like I got her last year.
I got a Beats by Dre and a designer bag from her.
God getting her as a Secret Santa is like jackpot.
I remember...
I remember like...
Talking to her.
And like her...
I don't know why.
I just remember like one point.
I was like...
Talking to her.
And she was like...
Oh yeah when I graduate...
Cause like you know she's...
Literally like a Saudi princess.
Apparently.
She's like yeah like I have to go...
I actually have a...
Beyonce.
And I was really young.
I was like in middle school.
And she was like...
A high schooler.
So like to me I was like...
A Beyonce?
Me thinking back I was like...
Wow you're gonna get...
You're gonna get married after you graduate.
Like I was like...
I don't know I remember I was super young.
I was in middle school.
And I was like wow do you know who he is?
And she was like no.
And then you know I was young.
I didn't like think about it.
And then I was like...
So that's crazy.
Anyway as I was saying.
It was this international school.
I used to go to cause I went to many international schools.
Like I traveled a lot.
Growing up cause I had to move around a lot.
And...
And like I remember just like...
Like to even like enter the gated community.
You need like a pass.
Because you know people don't want...
To have their child kidnapped.
Cause we also have like...
Also I think it's just really bad...
Poor planning of the...
Surroundings.
Because the playground was very near the entrance.
Where all the little kids play on.
So like I feel like...
Maybe it was also like poorly planned.
Because there was...
The playground was practically almost at the entrance.
Of the community.
So yeah you needed like a pass.
To even enter the entrance.
You needed a pass.
And drop your kid.
So like you need a special pass.
But yeah for those...
Like I said for those who don't know.
That's why I'm saying like a lot of people.
That...
That usually have...
You know a lot of the...
Especially like Americans.
People who don't live in the country.
The international school is in.
Usually the parents were...
Were assigned to work in that country.
As an expat.
And they were assigned to work in that country.
To like help with...
Expansion.
You know like expanding into a new country.
For the business.
For the company.
I remember like...
One of my schools that I went to.
One of my international schools.
Was like 60 to 70%...
Were like Koreans.
Because...
At that time...
Samsung...
Samsung was expanding their...
Business.
In this particular area.
So they sent a lot of like...
You know sent a lot of the...
A lot of Koreans to this particular region.
And so like...
You know their kids will go to my school.
And then like 60 to 70%...
Of the student body.
Yeah the Korean execs.
Will be like...
Would like attend my school.
And so that's how I learned Korean.
Because...
At that time...
I would you know...
I had a lot of friends.
Korean friends.
So that's how I learned a lot about like...
Like Korean culture.
Like Korean K-pop and all that stuff.
Like I was like you know...
Like now it's like BTS.
But back then I had Girls Generation.
Super Junior.
Big Band.
Stuff like that.
Like Big Band was pre BTS.
Before you guys had BTS.
Big Band walked for you.
Big Band and Super Junior.
Super Junior and Big Band...
Walked so BTS can run.
So yeah and 2NE1.
I love 2NE1.
I love... I don't remember 2NE1 songs.
But like I remember like...
I just love the name.
I thought it was like such a creative name.
Ummm...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Doki went to school with actual Ojo songs.
No I did.
I... One of... Okay so like...
In one of... Okay so in one of my international schools.
There's like...
I'll say... It's so fucked up.
But like there's like...
Special tuition.
For the...
For citizens of like whatever region.
I would... Like whatever country I was in.
So like umm...
Cause like international schools have this.
So like usually international schools.
Is for international students.
But...
They will make exceptions.
If you're really rich.
So...
Like they will... They will make exceptions.
To like the local...
Locals in the area.
If you're really rich.
They'll have like...
Jacked up tuition prices.
Just for like...
Umm...
Just for like the locals in the area.
So like if you're international student.
You would pay like you know...
1 sixth of that price.
But like umm...
Or you could say like if you're a local.
You would pay the tuition for that for a year.
Would be like times 6.
The original price of the tuition.
So I remember there was a girl in my grade.
Umm...
I was in middle school.
There was a girl... I think... Or like was that in high school?
I'm trying to remember which school this was.
But umm...
There was a girl in my school.
And then I remember everyone was telling me like...
Bro like...
Cause like we would be like...
Where are you from?
And then the girl would be like...
Oh I'm here from here.
Cause we would do like icebreakers being like...
Cause we're all international...
We're all like quote on quote international students.
From different countries.
So we would do like icebreakers being like...
Oh where are you guys from?
Like as your icebreaker.
Like oh I'm from Ireland.
Or like oh I'm from South Africa.
Stuff like that.
And then she would be like I'm from here.
So you know we all thought it was weird.
Hahahaha Hahahaha We were like...
What do you mean here?
Hahahaha This is an international school.
What do you mean you're from here?
Hahahaha Hahahaha And then...
I remember I was just like...
That's weird.
I remember I was like...
This is an international school.
Hahahaha Hahahaha Um...
And then I remember cause like...
She was...
She was fucking loaded.
Okay.
I don't know if this was like based off of like...
How rich she was.
But like...
Whenever we would have school trips.
Or like trips where like obviously...
Like the places we're going.
It's like not a great like you know...
Like maybe we were going to travel somewhere that was like...
Community service or something.
We had to do like community service and like...
Um...
We had to like...
Like we had to like you know...
Take a plane ride to a certain area.
And we'd do community service or stuff like that.
She would...
Hahahaha Hahahaha She...
I don't know how...
But like...
She would get like a permission slip.
Being like...
Oh I can't go.
I'm sick.
Hahahaha
She would... like...
Doing community service.
I was like...
Hahahaha She would literally be like...
Oh I can't go.
I'm sick.
So like she would actually get like a...
A note from...
Whatever maybe like the doctors or something.
Being like...
She can't do community service or like travel that far.
Because she's sick.
And then she was obviously not sick.
Cause she would go to school.
To give the slip.
To the teacher.
Hahahaha She would come to school.
To like give the slip to the teacher.
And just cause we all have to show up at school.
To take the bus.
Or like take the shuttle bus.
To the airport.
Hahahaha Hahahaha And then I remember one time I was actually sick.
Um...
One time like I was actually sick.
And I had to like...
And the thing is.
It's not like you just...
You don't go to school.
Uh... You don't go to school.
If you're like...
Sick, sick thing.
If you're not gonna go do the trip.
You still have to go to school.
And do like class work.
Because like it's technically a school event.
So...
I think I was sick.
I think like I twisted my ankle or something.
So I still had to go to school.
I couldn't participate in one of the community service trips.
So I had to...
I actually...
I actually like twisted my ankle from like one of the sports I did.
Sports I did.
And so but I still had to like show up at school.
Because I couldn't do the community service thing.
So I had to do class work.
And then like I see her.
I see her there.
You know?
And we all had laptops too.
So like when we were doing class work.
Because like it was me, her and this other girl.
And I would like do class work and stuff.
And then I look over.
Because we all had to sit together.
And I look over to my side.
And I see her looking at like buying...
Shopping.
I see her like online shopping.
And watching YouTube videos.
She does not...
I call bullshit.
I call BS.
She was not sick.
I know being sick doesn't prevent you from browsing the internet.
But...
There is no way she was sick.
Every time.
Every time we had community service.
There is no fucking way.
She was...
Every time we had community service.
She was fucking sick.
I refuse to believe it.
Oh my god.
But yeah.
That...
I...
I just...
That was like such a memory for me.
Oh yeah.
And then...
It won't be just one international school.
There was like...
Another international school.
Okay.
It's so fucked up.
It's actually like...
Really fucked up for me to say.
But we had a rivals...
There was a rival international school.
We had a rival international school.
But our school...
Was the more expensive.
Our school...
Was the better performing one.
The tuition...
Was more expensive.
And our students...
Performed better.
We performed a lot better.
So we had a...
We would do like...
You know, we would have like rival... the rival events and stuff.
So like also like to get in...
there's also like... I know like... it's also like a bit more... I think like I don't know how I...
oh wait, I'm trying to remember how I got in.
But like you had to take like tests and stuff too.
So like if you failed the entrance exam for my school or you have the money...
because I know... I know there's... I know damn well some of them...
there was no way they would pass the entrance exam.
I don't...
I know there's some people in my school there's no way they would pass the entrance exam.
They were loaded.
Anyway...
Um...
Anyway, as I was saying...
Uh...
So there was the rival school and the rival international school.
And like we had... there was like a huge rivalry between us two.
Because you know they're... they're... they're like not that even far.
The funny thing is that when we have like practices like...
Uh...
Like...
Like sport practices like...
Like soccer or like soccer practices.
There's only...
I think there's... there's like only one field.
There's only like one giant field.
And like... and it's so funny because...
And but there's like three... there's like three fields.
So...
So sometimes we would fight over which school gets to use the field to...
Which school gets to use the field for like soccer practice.
And we would be like...
Oh... there...
When we get to the...
When we would get to like the field and we see them...
I obviously I don't want to dox anybody.
So I'll be like...
Oh there they are.
There's that school.
We'll be like...
Oh my god there they are.
Like actual school rivalry and shit.
And...
And we'll be...
Oh and then we would be like...
Come...
And then I remember...
I remember we'll be like...
At least we're not...
I'm gonna try to make a name.
Okay...
At least...
I'm gonna make up like letters.
I'll be like...
At least we're not...
Y.O.T.
Stuff like that.
We'll be like...
Oh my god.
Like I can't believe this is happening to us.
But at least we don't go to Y.O.T.
Because we're all...
We were so pretentious.
Holy shit.
Because we always were like...
Our school is better.
Because...
Because we'll be like...
Oh my god.
At least we're not Y.O.T.
And at least we like...
We have better facilities.
And then...
And then you know the other school would be like...
Oh my god.
At least we're not like...
Them.
They're so fucking pretentious.
We had...
There was like one...
One person...
In...
Not me.
I wouldn't say it.
But like these are like the things I'd hear.
Like the things I hear and stuff.
Um...
And...
Cause like okay.
It's really...
Uh...
When I did like sports.
When I did like...
Varsity sports.
I was...
One of the only players in my team.
That would befriend other players in different schools.
So like I would like hang...
I would actually like...
Befriend like other players.
In like...
Uh...
Different schools and stuff.
So I had like...
I would just hang...
Cause I don't know.
It was fun.
Cause it was like...
Um...
An international school.
So I can meet people from different countries.
And I remember like...
When I was like...
I did soccer.
Um...
I would always hang out.
I would um...
Befriend like some of the really good players.
Uh...
From different schools.
Same with volleyball.
Uh...
And stuff.
And I would befriend like the players from different schools and hang out with them.
Usually...
Uh...
I was a little bit of an outsider.
In my teams.
Because I usually...
Uh...
Usually I wouldn't hang out with my team all the time.
And I would hang out with like...
Uh...
The other players in different teams.
Um...
And...
Oh my god!
I remember...
Uh...
I was like hanging out with one of the rival teams.
Because they had a really really good player.
Back then in one of the...
One of the...
In soccer in one of my schools.
I was known as like one of the best...
Goalies.
In our division.
So like out of all the schools.
I was like the best goalkeeper.
Um...
Versus like all the schools during like...
Because like we would have like tournaments and stuff with a lot of international schools.
From like different countries.
Um...
So like in one...
One time I was like the best goalkeeper.
In like in the division for like all the schools combined.
Um...
But...
But there was like this one girl.
Who was an insane...
Striker.
Like she was like the best.
Um...
She was like the best striker.
Out of all the schools.
She was the best striker.
And I befriended her.
Because you know I was like...
Bro she's so fucking good.
And then we would like every time we meet up.
Um...
Because she goes from a different school.
Like she obviously...
She goes to international school in a different country.
Uh...
So like every time we meet up in like a tournament.
Like um...
We would like practice against each other.
And stuff.
Because like you know if I practice against the best.
I can perform better against the other strikers.
Because she was known...
She literally got like a...
She literally got a soccer scholarship.
Uh for university.
Like because I like kept in touch with her for a bit.
But I don't talk like after you know after uh university.
Like obviously like you don't really keep in touch with a lot of people.
But like she she's so good that she got scouted overseas.
That's how good she was.
Like like usually scouting.
What happened you know in the in in the country.
But she literally got scouted overseas for a soccer scholarship.
That's how insane she was as a striker.
And like her entire family were like was obsessed with soccer.
Because like I would...
I think I was at the school for like two to three years.
So um a year passed.
And then her little sister uh was in the division.
And she was also a goalkeeper.
And I became friends with her too.
Because uh...
uh...
because uh you know I was like oh you're her sister.
And then you're also a goalkeeper.
So then we would like I would give her like tips and advice.
On like being a goalkeeper and stuff like that.
Like uh so like uh like her entire family was just really talented at soccer.
Um I remember it was a crazy moment.
She kicked me in the head the striker.
Because we were like we were facing them.
So...
hahaha and uh...
um...
that's where I lost a bit of my brain cells.
But um...
you know like obviously I had like I like protected my head.
Because like I dived over and like grabbed the ball and like huddled around it.
Um...
because I...
I aggressed her.
I pushed her.
Um...
like it was a huge gamble and I pushed her.
I aggressed her.
And then like I...
I like covered my head with my arms and stuff.
But she still like hit me.
hahaha...
I kept playing.
um...
But yeah no I usually um...
I like hang out with the...
uh...
I hang out with...
like I said I usually just hang out...
yeah yeah she was like oh my gosh I'm so sorry like...
uh...
you like...
like I said I usually hang out with like the players from the rival teams.
Because I thought it was like...
I thought it was cool.
I thought...
it was fun hanging out with like people.
I don't normally like...
talk like I don't like...
I have a rare chance to meet up with and stuff like that.
And um...
and it was like a fun moment being able to meet like with people from...
uh...
with people from like different countries and stuff.
Um...
Let's see.
I'm trying to like remember...
uh...
Fuck.
It was like...
How did I get to this part of the story?
Oh yeah yeah yeah!
Anyway about rival schools.
So like one time...
one time there was uh...
there was a guy in our class um...
who left our our school to go to the rival school.
Because uh...
because like he he was he was like...
well um...
because we had a teacher there that like I guess like made fun of him too much.
uh...
Because he was like the class clown.
He was the class cat clown in our class.
And I think he he didn't really like when he didn't like one of the teachers.
He really hated one of the teachers.
Which is understandable.
We all...
We had a teacher that everybody hated.
We hated her.
And she was like our math teacher.
And the thing is like nobody liked her.
Nobody liked her.
She was our math teacher.
But thing is her husband is also a math teacher as well.
Um...
But we all love the husbands...
the husband.
Um...
Because he was a really good teacher.
But the...
But the other teacher we hated her.
Hahaha.
Anyway...
One...
Alright...
One of the...
are the...
The...
The guys in...
The guy in our class really hated the...
Um...
The...
The math teacher.
The real...
The wife...
Really hated the wife.
But she was like really mean.
She was so mean.
Um...
And she graded really harshly.
Hahaha.
And then...
At one point, sometimes the teacher would follow the grade.
Like get a promotion.
They would get a promotion and we would have to see them again the year after.
So when he found out that she's gonna follow us, like she's gonna be the teacher for the grade above, he left our school and went to the rival school.
And I remember our class feeling so betrayed.
We'll be like, I can't believe he went to UOT.
I'll be like, oh my god, he's a UOT student now.
He's okay, like I'm gonna make up a mascot because we also have like school mascots.
And he's like, he's a fucking tiger now.
I'm just like remembering that part of my life.
And I was like, holy shit.
Oh, okay, I can talk about this without really like doxing anybody.
So like, you know, like I said, I would go to international schools around the world.
Not around the world, sorry, around Asia.
Sorry, around Asia.
But obviously at one point, I was like, oh my god.
I went to an international school.
I went to and I used to live in Hong Kong.
And one of my fav... and like during like the tournament circuit, there was one school that I loved seeing.
This was like one of my favorite schools that I loved seeing when facing during tournaments.
And like I was so happy.
I was so like whenever like whenever this school hosted tournaments, I loved that school because I just...
And it was... I don't remember the name.
But like this international school is like well known in Hong Kong.
And it's primarily Australians.
It's literally an international school just for Australians.
And it was so cool.
It was actually...
It was so cool.
And...
Yeah.
And then like I remember because like every time they would do a school cheer, they would be like...
Asi, asi, asi.
Oi, oi, oi.
And then I would do their cheer.
And that shit was so cool.
It was like asi, oi, asi, oi.
Asi, asi, asi.
Oi, oi, oi.
Every time.
I fucking loved that shit.
I would like cheer with them because it was such a good cheer.
So...
And I like...
That shit was so fire.
I loved like...
Just like competing against them or competing...
Like going to their school whenever like they hosted tournaments and stuff.
Because it was...
I wish I could do that every time.
I just... I don't know, it was just so fun!
Like, Australians are so fucking fun!
Like...
I like how someone's like, Every international private school...
Wait!
I like them!
I thought they were funny!
I thought they...
I thought the sports teams were funny!
Okay, maybe like the regular students might have been like... might have been too much.
But the sports team students were funny though!
But yeah...
I like them!
But yes, there was an international school in Hong Kong that was just Australians.
And it was like, you know, obviously like kangaroos and stuff like that.
Like their entire mascots were...
Kangaroos and stuff.
And yeah, they were pretty...
I thought they were pretty cool!
I thought the sports teams were pretty cool!
Guys, I thought...
I don't know the regular students, but the athletes there were...
were fun!
They were fun to hang out with!
I hanged out with them!
They had the worst...
...kids!
But the...
Bro!
I hung out with the sports team though!
They were so fun!
I don't know about the regular students!
...
But yeah...
I don't know.
International school is so different.
I mean, I went from like a private...
Catholic school...
to like...
a private Catholic school in Canada.
And then like I had to obviously move out of Canada and do international schools around Asia.
So...
So like...
I never had like a regular school experience.
I think.
Umm...
I never really had like a regular...
Oh yeah!
I was like one of the few students there that was not Catholic.
Or Christian.
I don't know!
I don't know the difference between Christian and Catholic.
Umm...
I don't know the difference between Christian or Catholic.
I either went to a private Catholic school or a private Christian school.
I don't remember.
Maybe Catholic.
Catholic sounds like something I said a lot.
Umm...
But...
But like...
So like in Canada I used to go to like a private Catholic school.
Umm...
But I was like one of the few students that was not Catholic.
Or like baptized.
So like I was excluded.
I was excluded with like religious events.
I told this story before.
But like...
Umm...
There would be like...
Like...
Religious events and stuff.
Where you have to be baptized to participate.
So if you're not baptized...
You have to do school work.
You have to be like locked in the...
Not locked in a classroom.
But like all the unbaptized kids would be like kept in the classroom.
To do school...
Classwork.
And then...
And then I would get so jealous.
Cause I would be like...
I wanna...
Cause then...
And we also couldn't go to confession.
And I thought...
I was really young.
You know?
Cause I was like in primary school.
So then I was like...
It's not fair.
I wanna go to confession too.
With everybody.
I remember...
I'd be like...
I wanna go to confession too.
Cause I didn't know what was going on.
I didn't know what was going on.
I was just like...
It's not fair.
Why did they get to do stuff?
And I had to be locked in...
I had to be in the classroom to do classwork.
And then...
So like...
And then we would have like...
Friday night.
Friday mass.
Um...
We would have...
Friday mass.
You know?
And then...
Like every...
Before we start the day.
And then obviously you're baptized.
You can go in the front and eat bread from the...
The Pope will give you like some fucking circular bread thing.
Are those bread?
I don't know.
I never got to try it.
Because I was not baptized.
So...
So you know how they handle those circular things you get to eat?
So they're like...
All the baptized students get to lie.
And then...
You get to line up...
And...
Get to line up...
And you get to eat that little special...
Like...
Circular...
Communion...
Oh...
Communion wafers...
And obviously I wasn't baptized.
So I didn't get to line up.
And I'll be like...
It's not fair!
Why am I not baptized?
They all get to eat those cool...
They look so cool.
But I felt so excluded.
I felt so fucking excluded.
I'll be like...
What am I not baptized?
Stop being... why don't I get to...
Why don't I get to...
Yeah, I had FOMO.
I had FOMO as a child.
That's how fucked up it was.
I'll be like, what does it taste like?
Why do they... stop being... I don't get to line up for it like they do.
And then obviously, you know, I'm not Catholic.
My family's not religious.
So...
We would have... I don't remember what the religious event was.
And... yeah, I got FOMO'd from not getting the circle bread.
So... and I remember because you know how like those like... what are those beads called?
The...
The rosemary's?
And then obviously like all the students who are like actually religious, they will have their very own rosemary's.
And stuff... and... oh, rosary.
Sorry, rosaries.
Sorry.
Rosaries.
They would have the rosary beads.
Um... and then... and then... I didn't... I didn't know!
I didn't get to try it!
I just saw everybody lining up and getting it every Friday!
So I got FOMO'd!
So anyway, the rosary beads.
And like obviously, like since you're not baptized, you don't have the pretty rosary beads.
So they give us the plastic blue ones.
So like, uh, we all... the unbaptized sinners will get...
Not baptized!
Unbelievers!
Get the plastic blue rosary's.
And then my friends surrounding me, they would get like the really pretty custom ones because...
Uh, they...
Yeah, why does everyone have the pretty necklace but not me?
I felt so ashamed.
It's actually crazy going to like this Catholic school.
I was like, why am I so ashamed of not being Catholic?
It's like, I felt like... I'd be like, why don't I get all this?
And I remember one time, I'd be like, Mom!
I wanna get baptized!
Mom!
I remember one time I like asked my mom that I wanna get baptized because I wanted to eat the...
I really wanted to go to confession!
I didn't know what was actually going on!
I had no idea what was actually going on!
I just felt like I just had FOMO'd.
The fear... I got left out!
So like, I was just like, I wanna be... I was like, it's not fair!
I wanna go to confession!
I don't know what the fuck confession was!
I just wanted to go!
That's how they get you the FOMO!
Yes, I almost got baptized because of FOMO.
But then my mom was like, what the fuck is wrong with you?
You're not getting baptized because you're a FOMO!
Because you're scared of being left out!
It doesn't mean...
You really wanna get baptized!
It has to be an actual choice from you!
Not because of FOMO!
It was...
Obviously I didn't know what the fuck was going on!
Michael, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Damn, I'm baptized!
Kids, leave me alone!
What the fuck!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Yeah, I had to...
I didn't get baptized for the right reasons!
Not because of FOMO!
Not because I was...
I felt...
I felt sad of being left out!
Because I didn't get the special wafers!
Super thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
As a catholic myself, I apologize on behalf of him for such discrimination!
FOMO!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Oh yeah!
What was funny is that the catholic school...
The private catholic school I went to was super competitive to get in!
But I literally got in via nepotism!
I think I told this story before!
But I literally got in because...
Um...
One of my cousins...
I think like one of my cousins...
Or...
Or like...
Yeah, one of my...
My mom's friends, kids, or cousins or whatever...
She used to go to this school.
And she was like straight A student.
Like one of their best performing students.
So then they were like...
Wait!
Dokia is related to her?
Oh my god!
That's alright!
You don't have to take the test!
They thought...
They thought I was gonna be the next her!
They were like...
She doesn't need to take the test!
She's in!
Because it was super competitive and you have to take a test and everything.
But because I was related to her and she was one of their best students...
I didn't need to take a test!
Instead, when I got in...
After like...
I think...
That was a mistake for them!
Because in like 2-3 years...
They put me in an ESL class!
By the way...
English was my first language!
But in 2-3 years...
I got put in an ESL class!
Because...
Because I was so stupid!
I didn't understand the concept of...
Okay!
The main reason...
Why I got put in an ESL class...
Is because I didn't understand the concept of paragraphs!
And...
The reason being...
Is that I took the instructions so literally!
So...
I was like...
The one person that actually got kicked out of ESL class!
After like 2 years!
They kicked me out of ESL class!
Because they were like...
Wait!
You're not actually ESL!
You don't have to go to this anymore!
So basically, what happened was that...
We were told...
That...
Paragraphs...
They have to be...
If you want to make a paragraph...
You have to make sure that it's around the same topic...
And...
And usually it's like...
5-7 sentences...
Uh...
Oh wait!
Not 3-4...
Okay!
I heard 5!
It could be 4-5...
4-5 sentences...
So...
I latched on to the 4-5 sentences part...
I didn't care!
I didn't care...
What the topic was...
Each paragraph...
I counted my sentences...
And I was like...
1-2-3-4-5...
Alright!
Next paragraph...
1-2-3-4-5...
And then they put me into ESL class...
Because I kept doing that!
I kept...
Counting my paragraphs...
I latched on to that for some reason...
And...
Also I could...
Okay!
To be fair...
That wasn't part of ESL class...
No!
It was that!
It was 100% that!
Because the moment we had the lessons about paragraphs...
They put me in ESL class...
Like right after...
I don't...
It had to be that!
Because right after...
The lesson about paragraphs...
I got put into ESL...
Um...
And then 1-2 years later...
They kicked me out of ESL class...
Because they were like...
Wait!
You're not actually ESL class!
You're able to learn the other stuff well!
Uh...
Hahahaha...
So...
I got kicked out after that!
I was like the only student...
Um...
Because there was like...
There was like 3 other kids...
3-4 other kids...
That was in ESL class...
I was the only one that graduated ESL class...
Hahahaha...
Because I realized I shouldn't be there...
Um...
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Um...
Squibbly thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Thank you for the super chat!
Yeah!
That was like...
It was such a...
Wow time!
Um...
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
She is so stupid!
She's the best!
I love her so much!
It's great!
I'm like relatable!
You watch me so you can feel like mentally superior!
Hahahaha...
You're like... Man I'm stupid!
But at least I'm not that stupid!
Hahahaha...
I'm like ESL just cause she can't...
She can't count paragraphs!
Hahahaha...
Um...
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I remember you said once you played center for basketball.
I still find it crazy for your height.
That's cool!
As a basketball fan.
Also unrelated but you get...
Yes!
I got the gifts from Anime North!
Um... There was like a lot of letters!
Also!
Uh... Speaking of like...
Uh... Gifts at conventions!
Um... If you want me to...
Um... If you are okay...
With me talking about your letters...
Or like talking about stuff...
About your gifts... Please feel free to like...
Write something down to say like...
Oh you have permission to talk about it on stream.
Cause I don't want to talk about something...
You know if it was like a private gift and you don't want it to be called...
Talk about on stream...
Um... I don't want to talk about it just cause like...
I'm worried about like you know privacy issues...
For you guys... So like if you really want me...
If you're okay with me to talk about it on stream...
Just feel free to write it in the letter...
And say that you're okay with it...
Being talked about on stream...
And yeah yeah...
I was literally put in center...
For basketball...
Um... Because uh...
Because I could jump really high...
Ha ha ha ha ha...
I was like... I played center position...
But I was like...
Um...
I should not have been center position...
It's so... It was so sad because...
Um... When I first tried it for basketball...
For one of the teams...
Um... The... The person that was center...
For the team...
Like you know... She was like a senior...
Well I wouldn't say...
Senior... It was middle school...
Ha ha ha ha ha...
So like... I would be sixth grade...
And she would be like an eighth grader...
And then I would try it out for the basketball team...
In sixth grade... And like obviously...
I had to compete with the eighth grade center...
But I... Can jump higher than her...
So like...
It doesn't... It didn't matter...
And she was American... So like obviously...
She was taller than me...
Ha ha ha ha ha...
I was a short Asian kid...
And she was American...
Ha ha ha ha...
And so...
So she was... She had some height on me...
Ha ha ha ha...
She was a lot taller than me...
I'll just tell you that...
She was definitely a lot taller than me...
But...
She was coasting... The thing is...
She coasted...
And the coach used me...
Against her...
Um... To like...
Because she was like... Oh I'm tall... I don't have to jump...
You know... Like that's her mindset...
I remember this...
Her mindset was like...
Oh I'm tall... I don't need to jump...
I'm fucking taller than the girls here...
I can literally just like...
Reach my hand out and just go...
You know...
And like hit the ball in the center position...
But like the thing is...
I jumped higher...
I could jump really high...
And like me jumping really high...
I could grab the ball...
I could like hit the ball before she could squat it...
With her height...
Ha ha ha...
So...
So basically...
When I was first trying out the team...
Um... The coach was like...
I don't care... I need position...
And then the coach realized...
I could jump really high...
And I could grab rebounds and stuff...
And so she was like... Wait you want to try center?
We're gonna have like a 5 on 5...
We're gonna put me on center...
And then like obviously...
The actual team center...
The main center...
Because she's been the center for like 2 years...
Because she's an 8th grader...
We're gonna fight against her...
So I'm a fucking 6th grader fighting against a really tall American...
Who's been on the team for like 2 years already...
Who's been the center...
And then I was like... What the fuck?
I was like...
What the fuck?
Why am I competing against an actual player on the team?
I'm trying out...
Like... I'm gonna try out...
And the thing is...
Obviously I was motivated...
You know?
I was very motivated...
And I was like... Okay I gotta fucking try...
And I was able to...
You know... Every time I swatted the ball...
I was able to like... Swat the ball...
Before her... And then... Oh I felt so good...
So bad for her...
Because the coach was like...
Because the coach used me...
As like...
Like an example...
And she was like...
See?
She's able to grab the ball...
Before you...
She's a 6th grader...
Who jumps...
And actually wants it...
Because the other girl was coasting...
Because she thought...
Nobody was gonna fucking get it...
Um... Anyway...
I took center position...
From her...
I ended up...
Taking... Becoming a starter...
I became the starter...
5...
And got into the team...
And I took center from her...
In 6th grade...
I became a starter...
Alright... Thank you for the super chat...
Thank you...
Doki will never be balling...
Doki is fucking balling...
Thank you for the super chat...
Thank you...
Because the other player...
The other player...
She coasted...
And never got better enough...
Because I would always...
Um...
I was like always...
I was very determined in like...
Being the best...
By the way I hated basketball...
By the way...
The other part of the story...
Was that I hated basketball...
Uh...
Like it was...
I didn't like hate hate basketball...
But like out of all the sports...
I tried out for it...
And...
Basketball was my least favorite...
My most favorite was soccer and volleyball...
I loved soccer and volleyball the most...
Basketball was at the lowest tier...
But like at that time...
I was trying out for all the sports...
Because it's like per season...
So...
But like I knew...
And I was really good at basketball...
Like uh...
And I was like really good at it...
So that's why like I played basketball...
Because I knew I was really good at it...
And I was super...
I'm still super competitive...
And the funny thing is...
I became the captain of the basketball team...
Um...
At one point...
Hahahaha...
It was my least favorite sport...
But I was the captain of the basketball team...
Not in sixth grade though...
Not in sixth grade...
Hahahaha...
Like I would always be like...
I hate... I don't like the basketball guys...
Hahahaha...
I just never enjoyed basketball...
As much as the other sports...
But I knew I was good at it...
Because I had really good hand-eye coordination...
I always had like...
Really good hand-eye coordination...
And...
Um...
And like uh...
And like...
And so like I just like playing a lot of sports...
And that's why I'm really good at FPS...
Oh my god...
One time...
One of my math teachers...
Who was like a coach of...
I don't know...
I think he was like...
I think he was a volleyball coach...
And he like...
Because I had a class...
He was like one of my grade teachers...
Like not math teacher...
He was like the grade teacher for us...
Like the homeroom teacher...
And I remember...
Because at one point I was like coasting...
Because I knew I was good at hand-eye coordination...
And I was coasting and stuff...
Like I didn't...
Because at that point I was like...
Oh yeah whatever...
I know I'm the best player...
I know I'm really good...
And um...
I remember like...
My homeroom teacher pulled me aside...
And was like...
No because they were like a volleyball coach...
They were a really good volleyball coach...
And they were like... They pulled me aside...
And was like...
Um...
I don't remember what he said...
He was like... He pulled me aside after class...
To talk about like...
Sports...
Like I think volleyball or something...
It was either volleyball season or soccer season...
And he was like...
Look Doki...
We know you have really good hand-eye coordination...
But you could be better...
You could be so much better...
I was just like... What the fuck...
He pulled me aside...
He was like... If you train harder...
You could be the very best...
You have really good hand-eye coordination...
You have so much potential...
I was like... What the...
I remember I was like...
I think I was in middle school...
And I was just like... What the fuck...
I didn't know what to say...
I...
I was already on the volleyball team...
That's the thing...
I was already... Bro... No...
Volleyball fucked up my arm...
Um...
I was a really talented volleyball player...
Uh...
Because in 6th grade... I was able to do overhand serves...
Um...
And that was like...
A huge skill to have...
As a 6th grader...
So like... Because they were teaching us...
Normal serving...
And I was like... Oh I wanna do...
I wanna learn... I would see people doing overhand serves...
Like... Oh I wanna learn overhand serving...
So like in 6th grade...
I learned how to do overhand serving...
While all the other 6th graders were doing underhand serving...
So like... And then on the team...
I was like... Really good...
At like... Serving...
My serves were insane...
Um... And...
To the point... Where...
I was like...
I would be put as the starter server...
That was like my position...
Because I could do overhand serves...
As a 6th grader...
And like... My serves are very hard to hit...
Apparently...
Because like... They were saying that when I serve...
The ball doesn't move...
The ball...
I don't know how to say it...
The ball doesn't spin...
And people were saying that...
It's so hard to hit...
Because the ball didn't spin...
When I hit it...
So like... It was harder to control it...
When you hit the ball...
So... I don't know how I did it...
I just fucking hit the ball...
Like...
I don't know...
So... Whenever I serve...
Cause like... I don't know why they couldn't hit it...
But they were like... Bro the ball doesn't move...
They were like...
It doesn't move when you serve...
So like... This is how intense it is...
When I serve...
I was starting server...
And I would hit... I would get our team...
10 to 15 points...
Umm...
I... Literally...
One... I remember...
Two of the schools we faced...
I would be put at starting server...
And I would get like 10 plus points off the bat...
By just serving... It was so sad...
It was so...
It was so sad...
I would get like 10 plus points...
By serving only...
Cause I was put at the starter...
And then like... I would just be like...
And then like... It was so fucking sad...
And...
I think like... It was like 7th grade...
Or 8th grade...
I fucked up my arm...
Because my coach...
Umm...
Do you need 25?
One time I got like 20 points... I remember now...
I can't remember the maximum...
I think I remember... One time I got 20 points in a row...
Against the team...
And I fucked up my arm...
In like either 7th or 8th grade...
Because my coach really wanted...
It was like my coach really wanted to win against this one game...
And I sprained my...
I had muscle aches on my arm...
To the point where like the coach...
All the coach did was like they applied cream to it...
Or something like muscle...
I don't know what kind of cream to it...
And ever since that day...
I couldn't do those serves anymore...
Umm...
Because it like messed up...
Like I over strained it so much from it...
That like I couldn't do the strain...
My career ended so...
No... I wouldn't say my career ended so fast...
Because I could still serve...
But I couldn't do that...
That serve anymore...
Like I couldn't do that serve anymore...
Umm...
It was so bad...
It was like one tournament...
It was one tournament...
Where I lost the power...
I think it was 8th grade...
It was 8th grade...
I think so...
Because it was like 2 years...
I was known as the best server...
And then like in 8th grade...
In 8th grade for one of the tournaments...
I fucked up my arm so much...
That like...
Umm...
I couldn't do that serve anymore...
I think like if I do...
I think like if I trained again...
If I could have trained again...
If I could try and replicate again...
Maybe I would have been able to grab that...
Been able to do it again...
But like it was just natural...
It was like a natural thing I did...
Like a natural talent...
Because like literally in 6th grade I could just do overhand stuff...
Ha ha ha ha ha...
Umm...
Yeah you're...
The legendary player that retired after getting over it...
They patched my exploit...
Guys there was a new patch guys...
There was a new patch...
Ha ha ha...
We got Doki2OP...
Must nerf...
Umm...
They literally nerfed me...
They did...
I was too good...
Yeah I got nerfed IRL...
They patched me out...
Bro the people hated...
They hated...
The thing is...
I could do whatever the floating shit you were saying...
Like the whatever...
When you guys were calling my serve like the floating whatever...
I could do that in underhand...
The funniest part...
Was that I couldn't do it overhand anymore...
So I started doing it underhand...
And I could do the float serve...
Like I could do it on underhand as well...
Umm...
So sometimes like if I had to...
I would use underhand serve to like guarantee it...
Because I knew how...
Umm...
I could do it underhand...
Like underhand serve...
But because like...
I don't know...
I just remember we got like 10 points from it...
Because it was like around that time...
We were down...
I remember we were down like...
It was like...
I think it was like 20 to 10 or something...
It was like 20 to 10...
And then it was my turn to serve...
Obviously I couldn't do overhand anymore...
Because like... I... It was...
I think like it was like...
It was a tournament after I fucked up my arm...
So...
And...
The thing was that...
Umm...
We had to win this game...
To head to semi-finals...
Because like it was such a weird bracket...
It was like first versus fourth...
Oh!
I remember!
Oh my god it was such a...
Really happy memory for me...
Because it was first...
First place versus fourth place team...
My team... My school was the fourth place team...
My team...
My school was the fourth place team...
And... Umm...
And like obviously we weren't guaranteed...
We weren't gonna win...
We thought we weren't gonna win it because we were fourth place...
Umm...
And like we were up against like you know...
The main team...
The main team that was first place...
And...
And we win it... We head to the semi-finals...
We would be playing against first versus second...
So... We would do like...
We would head straight to the semi-finals...
And play first versus second...
And like... I remember it was like 20...
20 to 10... And then I was up...
And I ended up getting...
I remember I got 14 points...
I remember...
I got 14 points with underhand serve...
Because my overhand...
At that time was not consistent anymore...
Because I would sometimes hit the net...
Because I fucked up my arm...
Umm... So...
I ended up getting...
But it was one set...
The thing is... We had to play two sets...
I got us the first set from that...
And then we won the second set...
Because the first place team was so sad...
HAHAHAHAHAHA...
I remember... Because the first place...
And I got MVP...
Because like MVP...
Was chosen by all the coaches...
Like every coach nominates like...
Each player from each school...
To get MVP... And I got MVP for that...
Like because all the coaches nominated me...
As MVP... And we crushed their morale...
By winning the first set...
That we won the second set...
And we were so happy... We got second place...
Because we were not good enough for first...
HAHAHAHAHAHA...
HAHAHAHAHA...
We were...
We were not... We were just happy to be second...
We were so surprised...
We were like...
Because we were not supposed to be there...
HAHAHAHAHA...
We were happy just to be second...
Because we did not... We did not win the semis...
We got like...
Too old... So fast...
HAHAHAHAHA...
But like... But I did the underhand serve...
The first set...
I did the underhand serve...
And it was a floater...
The ball didn't move... It literally...
The ball didn't spin...
So like... I remember... And I got like...
14 points from just serving...
HAHAHAHAHA...
Because I was like... Guys... I was like... I'm not gonna risk it...
Guys... I'm not gonna risk overhand serving...
We need these points... I'm gonna do my underhand...
HAHAHAHAHA...
Next... Thank you for the super chat...
Thank you... Thank you...
You're my favorite sports anime protagonist...
Thank you for the super chat...
Thank you... Thank you...
I tell you... I used to do... It's why I'm like...
Good at hand-eye coordination... Because I used to do a lot...
Of sports back then... Growing up...
From like... Middle school to high school...
Um...
So like... I had just had...
It was an easy transition to play like...
FPS games... Um...
But yeah... We were so happy for second place...
Like we literally don't... We were like...
We were not supposed to be here...
HAHAHAHAHA...
Um... Bite size...
Thank you for the super chat... Thank you... Thank you...
Uh... No wonder you can't read...
God had to nerve you in some way...
Thank you for the super chat...
Thank you... Thank you... I mean...
It was like... It was fun... I love...
I love doing... I think like a lot of my happiest memories...
Were just back then... Um... In middle...
High school... Where just like the sports...
That I used to play... Cause it was fun...
I loved... I loved being competitive...
Uh... You know like... I never...
I never realized...
How good I was at sports...
Until 5th grade...
Um... In Canada... I didn't really...
Do... I didn't really do sports...
We just had PE classes...
We didn't have like actual like...
Sports teams... I mean cause we were in like...
Elementary school... You know... We were in...
Elementary school... And the only...
Reason why...
I got into sports... Is that...
In 5th grade... 5th grade is when I actually...
Went to international school... When I started like...
Moving around...
And... Um... Obviously...
It was still elementary... Elementary school...
5th grade... Um...
And... I remember... Uh... We had like an after...
School activity... Where we could sign up for...
Several... Um...
Where we signed up for several after school...
Activities... One of them...
Was soccer... Um...
And then I would just like... You know...
I was one of the few girls that signed up for soccer...
Every... All the other guys...
All the other kids there were guys...
And... Sometimes...
There would be like middle schoolers there too...
So it was like super intimidating...
And stuff... And... Um...
In 5th grade...
Our goalie... We would do like...
We would do like...
We would do like... Uh...
Uh...
We would do like scrims and stuff...
Like... We would do like scrims... Um...
Uh... Where... We would play like...
Soccer... And stuff... And then I would play like...
As like defense or...
Offense... I played defense...
Or offense... And then on the last...
Day... Our goalkeeper...
Wanted to play offense...
And they told me...
They were like... Hey come through goalkeeper...
On the last day of the...
On the last day...
Of the after school activity...
And from there...
I... I caught majority...
Of the shots...
And that's when I knew...
I had really good hand-eye coordination...
And like...
I could be a really good goalkeeper...
And the coach there...
After the games... The coach there...
Was like...
You should try out for the soccer team...
In middle school... When you like...
For the year after... Like...
When you get to sixth grade... You should try out for the soccer team...
Like you should really try out...
For goalkeeper...
Like...
Because I caught...
Majority of the shots...
And...
The thing was that...
Like...
We were playing against like...
Middle schoolers too... So it was like...
Like fifth graders with middle schoolers too...
And...
I really... And then I had a really fun time...
I was like... Wait... Soccer is pretty fun...
Because like...
Before then... I was just like...
You know... I was just like...
Kickball... Yay...
You know... I was a fucking fifth grader...
But it wasn't being like... I love soccer...
I was just like... Yay...
Kickball...
And then...
Uh...
And then there... And then like...
I swapped to goalkeeper... I was like... Wait...
This is fun...
Wait a minute... Soccer...
Can be really fun...
And that's when I started doing...
And from there... I started participating...
In like... When I hit to...
Middle school... I started doing like...
Like everything changed... When I got to be a goalkeeper...
And then I started really enjoying...
Like sports... Because it was like...
I had... I had enjoyment...
Out of it... Uh...
I think... When I was in...
I would like... I really like being goalkeeper...
I don't know... I just like catching balls...
Like... I don't know... It's just fun...
It's just... My...
My goal kick... Was...
I had insane...
Goal kick... Goalie kick...
So like... You know when you get the ball...
And you kick it as a goalie... And you can do like...
The punt... My punt...
Would literally go all the way to the other goalie...
The other goalie...
Like...
Yeah... Like I would...
Kick the ball... And it would...
Like when... You know... Like the... The punt...
Not the like ground shot... Like the...
The punt kick... And they would go...
All the way... To the...
Other goalkeeper...
So I had to like...
Control it...
Because if I just kick it, it just goes all the way there and then the other...
Because I've done that a few times when I didn't know how to control it.
Because I would just kick it to...
Because I was just like, get it as far as possible.
Because you grab the ball and then you kick it.
So I was like, get it as far as possible.
So that I would just kick it and then we'll just head to the other side.
And then the other side goalkeeper would just pick it up and be like, what the fuck?
This was in 6th grade.
And then I had to learn how to control where I actually kick it to the...
I would kick it to the other side near the goalkeeper.
But not to the goalkeeper.
I remember because I would kick it to the goalkeeper.
The goalkeeper would catch it and be like, what the fuck?
Because people would be like, why is it here?
Yeah.
And then...
And then so I had to learn how to actually kick it to a player.
Instead of kicking it as far as I can.
But I miss soccer.
I miss soccer and volleyball.
Soccer and volleyball was my favorite sports of all time.
Broken bottom.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Are you the captain of Mario Sports?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I just enjoyed sports.
I enjoyed it.
Since middle school.
All the way to high school.
I really enjoyed playing sports.
It's just...
It's just fun.
I was a very competitive person.
Oh my god.
I...
Whoa!
It's almost two...
I yacked for so long.
Oh my gosh.
It's almost two hours.
Holy shit.
I had a fun time talking to you guys today.
I'm going to call it here because tomorrow...
Tomorrow...
There's an announcement stream.
And VR chat.
So...
I'm really looking forward to...
I'm really looking forward to explore...
Explore VR chat worlds with you guys.
And like just...
Just have fun with all of you.
Anyway guys.
I'll also have an announcement at the end of the stream.
So please if you want to...
If you want to like...
You know what the announcement is.
You gotta stick around to the end guys.
Yeah.
We gotta get excited for tomorrow.
Bite size.
Thank you for the 50 gifted chips.
Thank you.
Holy shit.
That's so much.
Thank you so much.
Thank you so much guys.
Dark blade.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
By the way.
Yeah.
Full 100% permission to talk about my gift and letter if you want.
I really hope you liked it.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
I really appreciate it.
Bite size.
Thanks for the yapping before bed.
It's good to have it back.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I want to make this...
Like I said.
I want to make this a consistent series.
This series was postponed for a little bit.
Because we had Tekken.
Then...
Tekken.
Then WrestleTuber.
Then Minecraft.
Back to back to back.
So there was so much stuff to...
There was so much stuff to do.
But the series is back now.
Unless I get in...
Get busy.
But yeah.
It was a fun time yapping with all of you guys.
I had a great time.
I'm always so busy behind the scenes.
But it's always nice to do a stream for you guys.
Or just hang out and talk.
Because I always...
I really enjoy talking with all of you guys.
And I hope you guys have a nice...
Nice...
Rest.
Or like...
A nice morning.
For work.
Or school.
Good yappernoon.
Hey Tenjin.
Hey.
I was just about to end that.
But yes guys.
I'll see you guys next time.
I'll see you guys tomorrow everybody.
As always everyone.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around.
To get that blood flowing.
And if you...
Sit up for me.
Head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.